[تصفيق]
مرحبا شهر اسبوعين اربع ايام باقي للسنه
الجديده 2023 انا بحط اهدافي هالسنه
انا حابب هالسنه العب رفع اقوال كل يومين
اقرا كتاب بالاسبوع ورجع شعراتك
شوي السنه الماضيه كانت اهدافي كمان العب
رفع افقال كل يومين اقرا كتاب بالاسبوع
وما صير اصلها والسنه اللي قبلها نفس
الاهداف واللي قبلها نفس الاهداف دون اي
نتيجه طيب ليش هيك عم تصير ليش على حسب
كثير دراسات 80% منها تتخلى عن قرارات سنه
جديده وحلول شهر شباط
حقيقه هاي حاله انسانيه منعيشه كلنا عندها
تغير كل اهم رقم بالتقويم نشعر بالتحفيز
والامل والالهام اول شهر اسبوع يوم بعدك
بتبرد همتنا ما منحقق الاشياء اللي نحن
بنحققها
الفكره انه نحن عم نعتمد على التحفيز
للانجاز
والمشكله بالتحفيز انه طاقه محدوده مؤقته
تاتي باوقات مختلفه قد تكون غير مناسبه من
النادر بنلاقي شخص حقق انجاز كبير من خلال
تحفيز فقط
انا ما بس اول سنه بحس بالتحفيز ولازم غير
حياته كل ما اشوف فيديو تحفيزه او صوره
رفيق الشاطر كثير
رح تتغير حياته 180 درجه بيجي بكره تتغير
حياتي 360 درجه
هذا الموضوع معاناه كبيره بالنسبه لك مثلا
اول يوم بالفصل بتكون الطاقه عالي وجهزت
خطه دراسه ثاني يوم بدرس ثالث يوم شوي
رابع يوم بدرس اقل خامس يوم ما بدرس
السادس
لطاقه دائمه وخطه
بعد بحث طويل انا اليوم واقف قدامكم لاقدم
لكم الحل الذهبي لتحقيق الاهداف
يكمن الحل بالتركيز على الطريق للوصول
للهدف وهون بتيجي اهميه العاده والروتين
من كثر ما العادات مهمه اهل زمان قالوا
جردم لا تجر عادي
انا عديت على المثل الشعبي شوي لحتى يقول
لا تجرب عادي تكون مفيده لك
نحن اليوم عنا نظره سلبيه للعادات
والروتين ولكن برايي هي الطريق الافضل
لتحقيق اي شيء صعب
النجاح الكبير لا يرتبط بالفعل الكبير
والمفاجئ بل ما نلاحظ انه يرتبط بالتطوير
البسيط عن طريق عادات ايجابيه على مده
طويله من الزمن
انت لا تعلو الى مستوى اهدافك بل تسقط الى
مستوى نظام حياتك اي عاداتك اليوميه جيمس
كلير من كتابه العادات الذريه
طب معقول انا فيني ابني عادات وغير حياته
اي معقول رح اخبركن
العادي هي ممارسه اوتوماتيكيه بعمل انا من
دون تفكير مثلا اول ما بفيق الصبح بلاقي
حالا
بعد الغضب لقى حاله
لما بكون عندي هدف كبير مثل تعلم اللغه
الانجليزيه
فينا سجل دورات او ادرس على النت او جيب
انسه او استاذ المشكله ما بطرق المشكله
الاستمراريه لانه راح التزم اول اسبوع
ثاني اسبوع ثالث اسبوع بس بعدين ما رح
التزم اما اذا بنيت عاده تعلم اللغه
الانجليزيه نصف ساعه كل يوم بعد فتره من
الزمن بصير بلبل بالانجليزي
اي عادي نبنيه على دائره من اربع اشياء
اشاره
الرغبه استجابه والجائزه اكثر عاده منتشره
هي اعاده استخدام موبايل الدائم
تكون قاعد اكل او عم ادرس والموبايل
قدامنا
ضو الاشعارات هاي الاشاره
بصير فكر بركي حدا بعث لي رساله مهمه
بركي حدا نزل بوست فيه صورته بركي رساله
الغاز هاي الرغبه
الاستجابه بتصير بشكل اوتوماتيكي انه انا
باخد الموبايل بفتح القفل وبروح على تطبيق
السوشيال ميديا والمكافاه هي الفيديو
المضحك او المعلومه او او
لحتى ابدا اي عادي في اربع خطوات ونصائح
الخطوه الاولى اجعلها سهله
بدي ابني اعاده العزف على الجيتار كل يوم
مساء الافضل حط الجيتار قدامه بالغرفه ما
اخبيه بالخزانه
نحن بنتخيل انه عنا سيطر على حياتنا وفينا
نعمل الشغلات اللي بدنا اياها لكن حقيقه
نحن بنعمل الشغلات اللي متوفره قدامنا على
هذا الاساس بنلاقي المسوقين بالمولات
بحطوا المنتجات الاكثر ربحا على مستوى نظر
الفئه المستهدفه لسهوله شرائها
انا استخدمت فكره قائمه المهام اللي نحن
عاده نستخدم الاهداف الصغيره تطبيق قائمه
المهام دائما بفتح اللاب توب وانا دائما
قاعد على اللابتوب فدائما عندي تفكير
بالوقت اللي انا بختاره لحتى يعمل لي
اشاره بلش بعاده معينه
ثانيا
اجعلها جذابه انا عملي يتطلب قراءه عدد
كبير كتير من المقالات
ضفت على هالعاده تسمع موسيقى مفضله الفكره
انه انا اشتهي رد على الاشاره
ثلاثه اجوا على سهله
بدك تحط الخطوات بينك وبين البدء بالعاده
اسهل واقل ما يمكن
مثلا اذا بدي العب رياضه بختار ناظر رياضي
قريب على البيت
اربعه اجعلها ممتعه
تاخذ كورس طويل وفيه فيديوهات كتير بعد كل
فيديو فيك كافئ حالك
طبعا الموضوع بيختلف من شخص لاخر هذا
الشيء اسمه عقد العادي يعني بعد العاده
الايجابيه بكافئ نفسي بما يناسبها بعد
العاده السلبيه بتكافئ نفسه بما يناسبها
الموضوع بيختلف كثير بين شخص واخر ولكن
الهدف انه يكون الموضوع ممتع بالنسبه لك
ينتج الرنين بالدماغ لانه الان قانون بقول
ما يكرر ما يكافئ يكرر وما يعاقب يتم
تجنبه لذا عليك وضع مكافات لنفسك على طول
الطريق
هلا في فكره ممكن تكون اهم للباطهم قال
اذا الفت الاربع خطوات السابقه فيني اتخلص
من اي عاده سلبيه او ما بدي اياها
واحد اجعلها مخفيه بدي اتخلص من عاده
استخدام السوشيال ميديا بعد ساعه معينه
اخفي الموبايل لحتى ما يشكل لك اشاره
للبدء بالعاده
اثنين اجعلها غير جذابه بدك تجرب هاي
العاده من اي شيء ممتع بالنسبه لك
ثلاثه اجعلها صعبه بدك تحط خطوات اضافيه
بينك وبين العادي وتكون غير ممتعه حتى
ممكن تحط عقوبه صغيره لك بعد كل عادي
بتعملها
انا هون كما استخدمت قائمه المهام نفس
الشعور الكتير حلو نحن بنحسه لما بنعمل شك
لما هم معينه انا صرت حسو لما يخلص اليوم
واعمل تشيك انه ما عملت هاي العاده
السلبيه
انا كانت بالقصه باول هدف دائم هو الرياضه
بعد ما عملت جدول العادات واكتشفت العادات
اللي انا عم اعملها شاب اكتشافه
اول اكتشاف انه الهدف اللي حاطه اليه هو
كتير كبير بوقتها بين شغلي ودراسه
تاني اكتشاف انه
انه بحل انا الوقت المناسب لحتى بلشوا
الرياضه هو بعد الشغل وقبل الغداء بهالوقت
بتحاكينا الوالده بتخبرنا نتغدى لما
نستناك انا بخليها تحاكيني وتقول لي نتغدى
لما بدك ترقد هالشي بخليني ابلش اللي هو
الاشاره
بالاضافه
انه صارت بعد كل مره اربط كافئ حاله بعصير
انا بحبه او حلقه من مسلسل انا بحب شاهده
الفكره اللي انا عم اطلب منكم انه كلنا
نعمل شيء اسمه جدول العادات
بدايه نحدد الاهداف اللي نحن عم نطبح
الحقيقه بعدين بنحدد العادات اللي
بتساعدنا الوصول لهاي الاهداف بعدين من
خلال الملاحظه على مدى اسبوع مثلا نكتب
عاداتنا اليوميه العادات اللي بتساعدنا
للوصول للشخص اللي احنا بنكونه منحط عليها
اشاره موجب العادات اللي بتوقف بطريقه هذا
الشخص بنحط عليها اشاره سالبه والعادات
المحايده بنحط عليها اشاره تساوي لحتى
نبلش عادي بدنا نكتب انه عندما يحدث الشيء
الفلاني الاشاره سوف اقوم بالرد التالي
الاستجابه طب انا كيف بضمن انه تصير هاي
الاشاره اللي بلش العادي من خلال عادي
سابق انت كنت تعملها
لهيك احنا عملنا جدول العادات هالشغله
اسمها طقوس في ناس تخبرنا انه انا عندي
طقوس محدده لحتى اعمل شيء محدد هي ببساطه
عندها عادات فوق بعضها مثال هون هو كورونا
وقت الكورونا خبرونا اهميه التعقيم وغسيل
الايدي اللي حط هالشي هدف واعتمد التحفيز
فقط لحققه حسب الهم كان الموضوع كتير صعب
بالنسبه له
اما اللي بنى عاده التعقيم مثلا بعد ما
يرجع من البيت هو دائما بحط المفاتيح
بمكان محدد بعد هالعاده اللي هو دائما
بيعملها صاروا يروح يغسل ايده او يعقن كان
الموضوع سهل بالنسبه له بالدلاله انه لحد
الان عم يعقم ايده بعد انتهاء الماركتينج
عن الكورونا
انا شايف اليوم في فرصه قدامنا غالبيه
الحضور جايين مع شخص من صديق او عائله
ممكن يساعدهم لبناء عادات ايجابيه تساعدهم
للوصول للهدف ابتداء من اليوم بدون انتظار
للسنه الجايه
طب ختاما هل فعلا تحفيز غير مهم تحفيز مهم
جدا ولكن هو جزء بسيط من معادله الوصول
للاهداف هاي المعادله اساس العادات
الايجابيه التي تدعمنا الوصول الى ما نريد
شكرا جزيلا استماعكم